very special Senate race tomorrow in in
in Alabama thoughts about that how do
you think's gonna happen
my gut is that Roy Moore will win and I
think we'll be surprised that you know
there are a lot of people who were gonna
vote for him who don't want to admit
they're gonna vote for him that's the
problem with polling is that when they
call people there are a lot of people
who don't want to admit that they're
going to vote for Roy Moore over the
phone remember he was supposed to lose
the primary and he actually won pretty
handily I think if you want to
understand the dynamic Steve Bannon went
out campaigning frame and he and he goes
there and he says to the crowd and he
says remember if they can destroy Roy
Moore they can destroy you so the whole
thing is this class cultural you know
revolt where he but but the steve
balance of the world are saying don't
let those coastal overeducated
you know cosmopolitan elites run your
life basically don't let Kohn and tell
you what how to live your life I'm from
Boston that part's true
my family I grew up my family very
impoverished and I had to really and I
was in a gang as a child
that's a great crib yeah we all wore
Lacoste shirts and again we roam the
neighborhood we had we had pleated pants
we were the only gang that had pleated
pants but you're right you see this
fundamentally as and I think a lot of
people forget that it's it's its class
it's a it's a division of classes yeah
and I Trump and again he knows how to
play it with this very well so people
are talking about the tax cards and
things he goes and picks fights with
football players for not for not just
playing the game in its you know you'll
notice it's invariably African American
football players he even during the
during the campaign he had this
Instagram feed where he would
occasionally put a photograph of him in
his private plane with a big bucket of
Kentucky Fried Chicken what he's
signaling to his audience is I'm just
like you I may be rich but I still like
Kentucky Fried Chicken there I go doing
brand advertising again but but I think
you know that's that the core of his
appeal is right he's saying to every
working class person if you were rich
you'd have a private plane but you'd
still eat at McDonald's you know he's
also sick
knowing that he's not going to live very
long but you know he doesn't believe in
X no he doesn't believe in exercise said
it robs the body of precious say I don't
know vital fluids precious Big Mac ya
know he is he's got so many people
believing that don't exercise and get as
much fast food into you as possible but
again and I've been waiting for a doctor
to tell me that my entire life so it's
genius I mean while you're telling
everybody to eat kale and arugula and
then those people that's wrong again
once again I was in a gang
you